[Music]
the left tonight continuing to
actively come promote what we call
cancel culture last week they tried to
cancel
goya foods simply because the ceo
praised president trump oh to think of
it
last night ivanka trump showed her
support for goya foods and
the work that they have done fighting
and delivering for
the hispanic community on twitter that
led to a backlash the mob in the media
the cancel culture movement
yesterday they found out well a new
victim l.a times contributor jody rosen
declared it's time to replace the
star-spangled banner
really joining us now with reaction the
host of the reuben report dave rubin
florida congressman matt cates
you know dave you have a book behind you
uh i believe it's don't burden this book
isn't that right
okay my question is why is it the
intolerant left
i don't like jimmy kimmel i don't like
bill maher i've defended them
and fought against firings now they want
to go after everybody what you said 25
years ago 30 years ago
and you know i supported joy reid when
they wanted to fire her
i said give her another chance i don't
support boycotts i don't support
firings i support giving people other
chances
maybe i'm just living in an
old-fashioned world where i understand
people are flawed make mistakes
and you know right to redemption and nor
do i support censorship or
trying to silence political views
yeah well i'm going to guess sean that
none of the people you just mentioned
have ever afforded you the same
accommodations when the mob has come
after you or tried to
take your sponsors or anything else but
i think there's a a reason for that a
fundamental
reason which is that people on the right
fundamentally understand that if you
believe in individual rights and you
believe in the constitution you
understand we've got 300 million people
in this country
they come from all walks of life all
different backgrounds they're going to
believe different things
their purchasing habits are going to be
different they're going to live in all
sorts of different ways
this new woke leftist marxist thing
it is a mind virus a virus is very easy
to catch
and very hard to get rid of and this set
of ideas that says you're morally right
all the time
and everyone who opposes you is evil and
that's work thus worth
boycotting or destroying or eliminating
from society
it sounds good it's attractive to young
people and we just have to keep beating
it
with better ideas if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell